the 2022 World Cup was built on slavely
see when FIFA awarded Qatar to host the
World Cup the 300 billion dollar price
tag to build all the stadiums and stuff
wasn't the problem qatar's got all that
oil money after all the problem was who
would build the new stadiums and
infrastructure the Qatari people are
rich they weren't gonna lower themselves
by doing construction work so what did
the Qatar government do they hired poor
desperate slaves I mean workers from
South Asia they promised them high
salaries good living good working
conditions Etc but when those workers
got the Qatar they had their passports
confiscated and they were pushed to the
brink of exhaustion they had to live in
disgusting labor camps and sometimes
they didn't even get paid for several
months in the end more than 6 500
migrant workers died and now that the
World Cup is over Qatar is getting rid
of all those peasants who made it
possible click the link in the pin
comment to watch our full video on this
because